wake up in the dark if you had the
screaming of the land there is nothing
better than coming out of a movie and
being absolutely terrified by a villain
some of the greatest are able to
penetrate our inner psyche having a hold
on us far after we've left the theater
but why are we so drawn to these
antagonists what is it about them that
keeps us coming back for more and what
does it say about ourselves today I want
to look at the villain in hero as a
clash of ideologies a clash that
transcends simple good and evil and
makes us think in question how our world
[Music]
Merriam Webster's defines ideology as a
system of ideas or ideals but I prefer
what American historian Morris Berman
said an idea is something you have an
ideology is something that has you
ideologies drive characters to action
opposing ideologies lead to conflict and
conflict leads to drama the bread and
butter of great storytelling so it makes
sense that a clash of ideologies will
provide much needed fuel for stories
whether it be in film a novel or even
videogames I want to look briefly at two
examples first die hard and then Star
Wars but I don't want to look at them
from the perspective of John McClane
versus Hans Gruber or Luke Skywalker
versus Darth Vader I want to look at it
from their respective ideologies and how
they resonate with us in the Society of
the time diehard came out in July of
1988 to huge critical success IFC called
it the best action movie ever made
reason 10 being that the title kicks ass
and makes no sense it spawned a new
genre film die hard on a bus
die hard on a plane get off my plane
die hard on up you get my point
but part of the reason die hard is so
compelling is because of its villain AFI
listed Hans Gruber is one of film's top
50 villains of all time but when you
break it down Hans is just a guy in a
suit with a gun the code he doesn't have
menacing red skin evident terrifying
dreadlock or even catchy one-liners so
what makes Hans work I argue that a
compelling villain is only as strong as
the difference in ideological values in
opposition to one another as Jon Truby
puts it in his book the anatomy of story
great drama is not the product of two
individuals butting heads it is the
product of the values and ideas of the
individuals going into battle so let's
take a look at one of these battles die
hard
mother die hard isn't just a film about
a cop versus a terrorist in fact I
wouldn't call Hans a terrorist at all
he's a thief plain and simple
but I need the code key because I am
interested in the 640 million dollars in
negotiable bearer bonds that you have
locked in your fault and the computer
money who said we were terrorists you
see Hans isn't fighting for a cause his
entire plan actually has no moral basis
he's not a freedom fighter he's not
fighting for something
Hans is in it for one reason and one
reason only pure and utter greed
it's interesting to note here that die
hard was actually adapted from a book
written in 1979 called nothing lasts
forever a time when the United States
was going through a crippling recession
brought on by you guessed it greed now
let's contrast Hans with Bruce Willis's
John McClane he is the exact opposite of
Hans
he doesn't wear custom designer suits
like him nice suit myself in fact for
most of the film he's in a wife beater
with no shoes
Jeb Stewart the screenwriter is quick to
establish this opposition early on when
John is picked up by a limo at the
airport it's my first time driving a
limo the limo being a visual
representation of wealth and excess John
refuses to sit in the back
preferring to sit up front to nail this
point further in a stroke of fantastic
dramatic irony I might add hans is
killed when john literally removes the
gold Rolex watch from his hand plunging
hans to his ultimate demise
John is your American everyman he is the
good virtuous hard-working blue-collar
American juxtaposed with the greedy vile
take the easy way out coughed every
cough East German and since I'm moving
up to kidnapping you should be more
polite one can't help but draw
comparisons between the ideals of
communism and capitalism that work here
keep in mind both the book and film were
made during the Cold War mr. Gorbachev
tear down this wall which leads me to my
next example Star Wars has arguably the
most iconic villain in all of cinema
history we are drawn to Darth Vader not
because of his cool costume menacing
voice or affinity for giant catastrophic
death rays we are drawn to him because
he represents the absolute anti ethical
values of Western civilization when we
are watching Luke and Vader battle it
out we aren't just watching a battle
between good and evil watching a battle
between freedom justice morality and
authoritarianism injustice and
immorality take a look at some of the
greatest villains of all time a
Mongolian Schindler's List Annie Wilkes
and misery Hannibal Lecter in Silence of
the Lambs or the Joker in the Dark
Knight now compare them to their heroic
counterparts see how their respective
ideologies clash so much so that each
scene has no possible outcome but to be
filled with conflict the foundation of
great storytelling so the next time
you're writing think beyond
stereotypical good and evil tropes think
about what your characters stand for
then maybe just maybe you'll have a
character who stands the test of time
[Music]
hey for those of you don't know I'm just
getting my channel started but if you
like what you saw subscribe share smash
the like button and check out my other
video I'm hoping to come out with new
content every month so stay tuned and
think story
[Music]